[Music]
what we not gonna do is have this Auto
tool man coming up here sellin the
sweaters and telling yah he stole half a
million albums cuz he did it Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott aren't letting
Nicki Minaj's shade get them down just a
day after attending the 2018 MTV Video
Music Awards the lovebirds were spotted
in New York City sharing a sweet smooch
on the street the adorable PDA comes on
the heels of some serious fighting words
from Minaj who previously slammed Scott
and Jenner on Twitter after Scott's
album Astroworld was deemed number one
on the Billboard Hot 200 chart following
the release of Minaj's album queen
sweetheart I'm not scared I'm legendary
any streets the rapper through even more
shade on Tuesday's episode of Queen
radio on Apple musics beats one accusing
Scott of using Jenner's fame to promote
his music Travis Scott on Thursday when
he realized the Queen was about to have
the number one album in America he and
his label decided to have Kylie and baby
stormy put up a tour pack he had her
going post and say hey I can't me and
stormy can't wait to see ya Minaj also
had a problem with him selling merch and
tickets for his upcoming tour with album
downloads and having that count toward
album sales
how are you selling something that does
not have anything to do with your album
but it's being counted on Billboard as
album sales
you
[Music]